Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich ich
bin gerade in Amsterdam und gucke durch
mein Hotelzimmer auf eine verregnete
ziegelsteinmauerort und es ist jetzt
nicht so dass Amsterdam viele da weiß
Amsterdam so schön ne ich mag diese
Stadt du hast immer das Gefühl ein
bisschen wie Venedig aber nicht mit
dieser unfassbaren Masse von Touristen
muss immer das Gefühl du raselst so
durchs Mittelalter weißt du das so schön
ich mag diese richtig Tour diese diese
schmalen windschiefen Häuser und und
dann überall dieses dieses ruhige stille
Wasser das liebe ich so sehr ich komme
ja aus einer Gegend ja hast aus dem aus
den Bergen auf den Dolomiten das ja
Wasser immer wild und Raum da raus ist
immer den Berg runter ja und dann kannst
du niemals irgendwie einfach mit dem
Floß sich draufsetzen und mal ein
bisschen durch die Gegend paddeln und
das könntest du halt dort
dazu eine Ruhe ich mag das wahnsinnig
gerne und die Vorstellung dass Du da in
so einem Land bist das unter
Meeresniveau liegt das heißt da draußen
ist irgendwo so weißt du so Frank
schätzingmäßig so das ungeheuerlich
fließende Wasser deswegen verstehe ich
auch warum die Leute dann zu Beruhigung
wahrscheinlich ständig sich irgendwas
durchziehen also Markus ich finde das
wahnsinnig sympathisch wie du mir den
Ausblick auf die Ziegelsteinmauer
in ein illusionskino ja verwandelt ja
ich gucke jetzt auf die Mauer und stelle
mir vor dass wenn die schönen Grachten
genau du kennst das doch der andere
heller die waren Abenteuer sind im Kopf
ja oder Arno Schmidt ne ich hatte den
letzten Mal erwähnt ja das ist dieser
deutsche Schriftsteller der sehr
sprachexperiment geschrieben hat der
gesagt hat die Welt der Fantasie ist die
wahre Welt
und dann frage ich mich immer ne so
Kulturpessimist wie man ja so in manchen
Stimmungen ist wird das ewig so
weitergehen also werden wir auch in
Zukunft so Fantasie begabte Kinder haben
die von sich aus sich ganze Welten
erfinden sowas oder sind die
vorgefertigten Welten ja überall immer
schon da dass sie Hase und Igel spielen
und sich nichts mehr ausdenken müssen
richtig richtig so du ahnst worauf ich
hinaus will du baust mir gerade eine
perfekte Amsterdamer Brücke sozusagen ja
ich wollte mit dir genau darüber reden
über diese vorgefertigten Welten über
das was Kinder Jugendliche aber auch
Erwachsene was die auf Ihrem iPhone
haben auf Ihrem Smartphone haben und was
das mit unserer Gesellschaft macht und
ich sag dir kurz den Hintergrund ich
hatte vor ein paar Tagen eine Begegnung
mit Silke Müller seine Schulleiterin aus
Niedersachsen
sehr kompetente
hoch sympathische und und kluge Frau
liebe Grüße an der Stelle die ein
aufrüttelndes Buch gemacht hat wie
verlieren unsere Kinder und dieses Buch
beginnt mit folgenden Zeilen ich trag
mal kurz vor ich halte das nicht mehr
aus Frau Müller jeden Tag schreiben die
mir Sachen wie du billige wärst Du
doch nur schon im Bauch deiner Mutter
verreckt und mein Video taucht immer
wieder irgendwo auf keiner hilft mir ich
will die Schule wechseln am liebsten
wäre ich tot Isabell 14 Jahre alt so und
sie fragt sich was passiert da gerade
berichtet von Videos die sich die Kinder
im im Schulbus schon morgens beehrt ob
hin und her schicken wo wo Menschen das
hat sie in der Sendung erzählt weil
lebendigen bleibt einfach kastriert
werden also
distische Folter Videos werden da
einfach geteilt und auf die Frage habt
ihr das häufiger mal ja
selbstverständlich
wir wissen gar nicht was wir uns alles
gegenseitig so zuschücken schicken und
oder andere Sachen ja also dick Pic
challenges also irgendwelche Mädchen die
sich dann als 16-Jährige ausgeben obwohl
sie in Wahrheit erst 13 sind dann
irgendwelche wildfremden Typen
anschreiben und sagen du schickst schick
mir mal einen sogenanntes dickpic und
der schickt er das dann und dann wird
das geteilt und so weiter und dann die
juristische Dimension dabei ja in dem
Moment wo du als Eltern oder als Lehrer
das dann siehst
und und quasi an dich nimmst und dann
die die Eltern informiert machst du dich
auch strafbar ja ja bist du Besitz von
Kinderpornografie zum Beispiel ja und
all diese Dinge also Vergewaltigungen
von Kindern alles wird dort auf den
Smartphones geteilt und sie fragt sich
wann ist unsere Generation und damit
meint sie unsere Generation ja wann sind
geboren genau wann haben wir verlernt
uns für Demokratie Frieden Respekt und
Toleranz einzusetzen und was passierte
eigentlich mit uns und dann siehst du
noch so ein paar andere Dinge Studien
Jugendforscher die sagen noch nie gab es
so viele unglückliche Kinder in
Deutschland und und ähnlich wir haben
schon ein paar mal drüber gesprochen
diese diese Traurigkeit bei jungen
Menschen heute diese ich will nicht
unbedingt Traurigkeiten nennen aber
diese Melancholie die über vielen liegt
so was leeres vielleicht ist das das
richtige Wort dafür das habe ich so oft
erleichtert ja genau dann dann neue
Wörter über die sich Psychologen
plötzlich unterhalten smombies ja das
ist die jugendsprachliche Abkürzung für
Smartphone Zombie ja
zum Beispiel ja oder ein ein nomophobie
ja die no mobile phone phobia ja also
die Angst davor sozusagen ohne Handy zu
sein oder einfach vorbeischauen also
dass man sich einsam fühlt wenn man
nicht online ist genau so und
gleichzeitig dann diese Diagnose wird da
wachsen junge Menschen heran aber ich
würde sagen auch wir selber sind längst
so mit so einem ganz hohen
narzisstischen Anspruch wir wollen alle
was ganz Besonderes sein und so
präsentiert man sich dann auch auf
Social Media vor allen Dingen und
gleichzeitig eine ganz geringe die die
Fachleute nennt das Frustrationstoleranz
ja also wenn man dann kritisiert wird
dann ist man alle sind sofort beleidigt
alle ziehen sich sofort zurück alle sind
sofort im Büro muss gar nicht erst
kritisiert werden das reicht schon wenn
man ein paar Sekunden lang keine
Aufmerksamkeit im virtuellen Raum
bekommen so genau also es passiert ja
was in dem Moment im Gehirn richtig ja
und das ist ja also der der Mensch hat
ja eine Art Werkseinstellung aus ganz
ganz vielen Stoffen und das vier
haupttransmitter
und das wenn die sich so halbwegs gut
balanciert sind ist schon mal ganz gut
fürs Leben das heißt also wenn die
erregungsstoffe in dir sich in einem
gesunden Verhältnis bewegen zu dem
beruhigungsstoffen
und das was du in Amsterdam gerade
einatmest wenn du genau
wenn ich jetzt das Fenster aufmachen
dann würden Stoffe machen die vor allen
Dingen meine Zero tuneIn also mein
beruhigungshaushalt
würde mich unfassbar gelassen machen
kann
wir finden das ja normalerweise spannend
wenn wir irgendwas haben was uns ein
Kind gibt was uns irgendwie fesselt
unser Aufmerksamkeit gefangen nimmt und
dann haben wir Dopamin Ausstöße dopamin
ist ist wenn manche sagen Glückshormone
ist ein bisschen falsch ich würde eher
sagen das ist so ein Einpeitscher werden
Erreger
und wenn man sich dann so eine hohe
Dopamin Dosis gewöhnt ist dasselbe als
wenn man sich an eine hohe zuckerdosis
gewöhnt oder in eine hohe Alkohol Dose
ist es fehlt einem was wenn man diesen
nächsten Kick nicht bekommt und das ist
das was ganz ganz stark passiert wenn
Menschen die gewohnt sind wahnsinnig
viele Reiz am Tag zu empfangen diese auf
einmal nicht mehr empfangen und der
gefährlichste dieser Reize ist dir
selbstbestätigungsreiz also arme
Menschen sind Menschen die ein sehr
hohes Maß oder eine sehr hohe Frequenz
von Selbstbestätigung brauchen bisschen
Selbstbestätigung braucht jeder ja aber
wenn das am Ende minütlich oder
sekündlich ist dann hat man eine total
Meise und das Züchten wir im Augenblick
millionenfach milliardenfach
milliardenfach und man kann das Messen
ne also ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden
verbringt jeder Deutsche mittlerweile im
Schnitt mit seinem Smartphone das ist
die eine Zahl aber die Zahl die dich
wirklich schockiert ist die andere wir
greifen im Schnitt 88 mal am Tag zu
diesem Teil 88 mal am Tag meistens
völlig unüberlegt einfach hin ich frag
mich wenn ich so eine Zahl höre wie viel
Zeit Menschen haben die meisten Menschen
arbeiten
88 mal 100 %.
guck mal richtig drauf ist da irgendwas
für immer froh ich bin froh wenn ich
nicht dran gehen muss also ich bin doch
jemand der so
SMS manchmal drei Wochen später
beantwortet ich weiß also ich das ist
das wirkt dann natürlich irgendwie
unfreundlich ja ja ja ja das wird
unfreundlich aber ich finde das ist ein
gesunder Selbstschutz ich erwarte ja
auch umgekehrt wenn ich eine SMS schicke
nicht eine sofortige Reaktion das werde
ich mir merken Richard aber im Ernst
sicher ich meine es ist ja an vielen
Stellen und das ist ja jetzt auch genau
die Grad Wanderung die die wir beide ja
heute auch machen du kennst ja meine
Haltung zu diesem Thema und ich weiß
dass deine ganz ähnlich ist wir sind
weiter von entfernt
soziale Netzwerke es Smartphones und so
weiter jetzt einfach so in Bausch und
Bogen zu verdammeln und zu sagen ist
alles Teufels Zeug und gehört dringend
abgeschafft und so weiter aber ich muss
dir sagen dieses Buch von Frau Müller
das Gespräch mit sie Kinder das was man
dann erfährt wenn man sich mal ernsthaft
anfängt damit auseinander setzen die
Erinnerung an ein Interview mit einem
Investor im Silicon Valley vor zwei
Jahren der mir sagt ihr denkt immer wenn
wir anfangen neue Apps aufzusetzen dann
holen wir uns einfach ein paar schlaue
Programmierer und dann denken sie sich
irgendwas lustiges aus das ist eine
völlig falsche Vorstellung wenn wir
anfangen neue Produkte zu entwickeln
dann denken wir über Verführbarkeit nach
dann reden wir mit Psychologen dann
reden wir mit Neurologen dann reden wir
mit Menschen die uns die Frage
beantworten wie machen wir die dies
benutzen auf gut deutsch maximal
abhängig ja so und das hat muss ich dir
wirklich sagen jetzt bei mir etwas
ausgelöst und ich frage mich
wie soll das weitergehen wie sollen wir
bei das da was passiert wir haben ja
über Moldau gesprochen wie wie
vielen Formen genau wie das die Menschen
wirklich wuschig macht und verrückt
macht das ist das eine aber auch dieser
diese dieses Thema Narzissmus der Umgang
damit du du sitzt auch im Restaurant es
gibt keine Minute mehr in den ich jemand
irgendwann dann wieder so ganz beiläufig
sitzen zum Telefon greift und dann ist
er wieder raus aus diesem Gespräch das
verändert das menschliche Miteinander
das verändert alles und ich ich habe
mittlerweile das Gefühl und auch auf die
Gefahren dass ich wie ein ein
Opfer Klinge der jetzt irgendwie von
ganz finsteren und sehr vergangenen
Zeiten erzählt dass das geht so nicht
weiter
also du hast jetzt so eine schöne
Situation wie ein Restaurant genannt ja
was geht denn an ganz normalen Frühstück
oder Mittagstischen ab
wenn man drei pubertierende Kinder hat
z.B das könnte man sagen einfache Regel
und sagen also wenn wir als Familie
zusammen sind ja ob wir irgendwas
gemeinsam spielen oder für gemeinsam
essen oder so dann sind die Smartphones
aus
wäre ja einfach
der Idee nach wird in der Praxis zu
Krieg führen und dann wird ein Streit
vom Zaun gebrochen und dann wird der
eine oder die andere pubertierende den
Tisch unter Protest verlassen im
Begleitung des Handys richtig weil dann
ist die die Sucht am Ende wichtiger und
dann ist man in irgendeiner
Chat-Community und wenn man da nicht
sofort antwortet dann ist man raus aus
der Verlosung das heißt es entsteht ja
auch ein Erwartungsdruck der anderen
dass man entsprechend funktioniert das
war ja das was ich am Beispiel der SMS
oder der E-Mail sagen wollte also wir
haben eine von zwei Seiten müssen wir
das sehen das eine ist meine Sucht
darauf eine Resonanz auf das zu kriegen
was ich da eingebe und das andere ist
die Erwartungshaltung der anderen dass
man in dieser Rolle funktioniert und das
kann man gar nicht voneinander trennen
richtig
aber was folgt daraus Richard weil es
gibt ja es gibt ja die Gegenstände es
gibt kluge Leute die sagen okay pass auf
hier mit eurem Kulturpessimismus
entspannt euch mal das Smartphone ist
keine Gefahr natürlich ist das
Smartphone keine Gefahr es ist der
Umgang damit über dem wir natürlich
dringend reden müssen am dieser Umgang
aber wiederum den halte ich mittlerweile
tatsächlich für eine Gefahr also die
Frage ist wie reagierst du als
Gesellschaft auf das was da passiert
mich mit mit Silke Müller unterhalten
und nach diesem Gespräch ich bin aus
dieser Sendung rausgegangen und ich du
kennst mich bin immer tolerant bis zum
geht nicht mehr ich ging da raus und
dachte weißt du was zu viel finden
lassen Sie alle wegwerfen aber das ist
natürlich auch nicht die Lösung das ist
natürlich auch nicht die Lösung und wenn
man sich jetzt einfach mal vorstellt
sagen wir mal Teile dessen was auf dem
Smartphone Relevanz hat und ich glaube
wenn man mal rein die Zeit betrachtet
mit was verbringen die Leute ihre Zeit
wenn sie Smartphones benutzen wenn man
mein Smartphone prüfen würde würde man
wahrscheinlich feststellen was am
häufigsten von mir benutzt ist es so
Wikipedia
kommt ausgesprochen häufig vor aber das
ist nicht so richtig repräsentativ ich
glaube dass dieses in sozialen
Netzwerken sich umtreiben aber Instagram
und tiktok und so weiter dass das mit
Abstand die meiste Zeit der
durchschnittlichen Handynutzung umfasst
genau wenn man jetzt nur ich meine das
nur als Gedankenexperiment ich habe das
nicht vor ja sie einfach mal vorstellt
es ist der Staat würde sagen ja jetzt
haben wir festgestellt also die Leute
treiben sich da wahnsinnig viel rum
vernachlässigen tausend andere Sachen
dabei und wir stellen fest und da haben
wir ziemlich gesicherte Daten unterm
Strich wird keiner glücklicher dadurch
und der Staat würde jetzt unter dem
Gesichtspunkt oh das macht meine Leute
unglücklich und unzufrieden und das
schlecht für den sozialen Frieden und so
weiter hingehen und würde sagen so das
Sperren wir einfach per Knopfdruck so
und statt die Nordkorea kann sowas ja
machen Bescheid einfach das sind jetzt
erstmal vor drei Monate lang keine
sozialen Netzwerke mehr was würde dann
passieren so und am Anfang gab es dann
Entzugserscheinungen ne und und
Irritation und man könnte nichts
miteinander anfangen und sagt der Zeit
würde man so ein bisschen in die alten
Muster zurückfallen wie bevor es soziale
Netzwerke gehabt hätte eigentlich einen
guten Effekt
ärgerlich an dem ganzen Experiment ist
das können wir natürlich gar nicht
machen weil wir Liberale Demokratien
sind und weil es auch toll ist dass wir
Liberale Demokratien sind das könnten ja
nur autoritäre Systeme machen weil er
liberalen Demokratie würde man sagen wie
viel Zeit ich an meinem Smartphone
verbringe unten mit was und das würden
wir mit guten Gründen sagen ja das geht
den Staat nichts an das heißt also wie
und wo will man was verbieten wenn ich
höre das in Südkorea ja äh ist ein
Gesetz gibt das offensichtlich Eltern
bestraft die ihre Kinder zu viel zu
lange Zeit und unbeaufsichtigt mit ihrem
Handy spielen lassen dann frag ich mich
ist denn Südkorea noch eine liberale
Demokratie was geht den Staat das an
aber der Punkt Richard was was passiert
da ich meine wir haben ein ganz kurz
darüber gesprochen du sagtest dass das
Bild das da gerade vor deinem inneren
Auge entsteht und das war ja glaube ich
auch die große Angst unsere Eltern immer
und das ist auch die Angst die alle
Eltern haben deswegen hat sich auch
dieses Thema so angefasst und aufgewühlt
also jetzt mal abgesehen von diesen
Inhalten die grauenvoll verstörend sind
und man fragt sich natürlich was
passiert mit Menschen dass das kennt man
ja auch aus der gewaltforschung also für
sich Soldaten den in Kriegen schlimme
Dinge erleben und die dann aber
irgendwann über so einem bestimmten
Punkt von Gewalt hinweggehen das heißt
anfangen andere Gefangene zu quälen oder
sogar zu enthaupten und so weiter man
fragt sich immer wie können Menschen das
die Wahrheit ist wenn man mit sich
gegründet hat mir das erzählt mit der
ich gerade den den
gemacht habe die hat mal lange
Interviews mit solchen Leuten geführt
und sagte dieser Gewalt Porno der da im
Kopf stattfindet das prägt die für den
Rest ihres Lebens und die wollen darüber
reden die identifizieren sich darüber
das ist für die etwas ganz großartiges
und macht sie am Ende so kaputt dass ich
die meisten von den am Ende das Leben
nehmen
und ganz andere Ebene aber diese diese
sozusagen grenzüberschreitende diese
Lehre die dabei entsteht dieser digitale
Burnout von dem man Psychologen auch
mittlerweile sprechen der Macht mit da
tatsächlich Kopfzerbrechen und auch die
Frage führt das zu so einer völligen
fantasielosen Gesellschaft also wenn du
sozusagen etwas in der Hand hast was dir
ständig alles liefert an Bildern an
Content wie man heute sagt das heißt du
musst dann der eigene Fantasien
Fantasien im Grunde gar nicht mehr
bemühen ja wenn du ein Buch liest dann
liest du ja etwas und baust dir selber
die Bilder dazu im Kopf in dem Moment wo
du nur noch auf auf Videos starrst ist
das vorbei ja das ist eine andere
Dimension fehlt also für meine Eltern
das begann das ja schon bei bestimmten
Formen von Spielzeug also wenn Spielzeug
zu perfekt ist das war in meiner Zeit
Elektrospielzeug ne also Autos die
Fernsteuerung fahren konnten und so
weiter die musste man nicht mehr selbst
bewegen man musste sich also jetzt nicht
mehr vorstellen dass das Auto von fährt
sondern es fuhr von alleine da ging das
im Grunde genommen schon los und ich
würde so unter pädagogischen
Gesichtspunkt sagen das beste Spielzeug
was es überhaupt gibt sind Bauklötze und
Pappkartons oder vielleicht noch ein
paar Decken und paar Wäscheklammern ja
weil wir haben auch sowas ja haben wir
unsere ganzen Wochenenden verbracht uns
Buden zu bauen also wir durften bei uns
in der Wohnung ja relativ viel werden
überfahren sind zwei stöckigen Wohnung
dann haben wir dann unter der Treppe
dann haben wir dann alles zugehangen und
mit Kartons fast gebaut oder mit
Pappkarton und Decken und Klammern und
Häuser gebaut und Spiele dazu ausgedacht
und so weiter so konnte man also
unentwegt die Zeit verbringen man
vergast zu essen man vergaß anderes zu
machen aber im Flow und das Beste daran
ist man ist am Abend ziemlich glücklich
eingeschlafen richtig wenn man jetzt den
ganzen Tag Fernsehen geguckt hätte eine
Erfahrung die mir leider verwirrt
geblieben ist aber die ich von anderen
kenne natürlich den ganzen Klamotten
geguckt den ganzen Tag Männer wärst du
nicht befriedigt ins Bett gegangen du
wärst du einerseits überdreht genau auf
der anderen Seite leer weil dein Körper
hätte keine selbstbestätigungserfahrung
gehabt deine soziale Fantasie wäre nicht
hinreichend bedient worden und so weiter
das ist du würdest den Preis für diese
Droge bezahlen die richtige genommen
genau das Leben altmodischen Beispielen
beschreibe ja das ist sozusagen die
Blaupause für das was ich heute
milliardenfach abspielt und ist triggert
haben uns beide schon mal drüber
unterhalten und das Sagen offensichtlich
auch viele Fachleute dieser Nazismus der
dann steht also die sozusagen diese
dieser übersteigerte Nazismus was macht
der mit uns wo sind ja nicht nur die
Jugendlichen Himmels will ne sehr sehr
groß unsere Generation wir sind die die
uns am am seltsamsten wenn ich finde es
sollte als Suchtkrankheit starke
anerkannt werden man denkt ja schon
darüber nach also Menschen die diese
unausgesetzte Befriedigung brauchen dass
die Resonanz auf etwas was sie im Netz
hinterlassen haben sein dass
irgendwelche Kommentare oder Bilder von
sich und so weiter die Unentwegte
Bestätigung brauchen jetzt nicht
aushalten können auch nur einen Tag dort
keine zu bekommen keine likes die haben
ein ernst zu nehmen gesucht Problem und
ich denke mal das muss man therapieren
weil ich meine was wird denn aus einer
Gesellschaft wo alle Menschen in diesem
Ausmaß auf sich selbst konzentriert sind
genau das ist die Frage so würden
liberal demokratische Gesellschaften
nicht funktionieren können weil sie auf
soziale Interaktion angewiesen sind die
nicht allein der Befriedigung von
heitelkeit dient
sondern auch Austauschbeziehungen
sondern von Eltern die sich liebevoll um
ihre Kinder kümmern und Menschen die mit
ihren Nachbarn reden und so weiter und
wenn wir das alles im Ansatz sehr schon
gar nicht mehr hätten ja Arbeitskollegen
die sich füreinander nicht mehr
interessieren und so weiter funktioniert
keine
gesellschaftliche liberale Demokratie
wird nicht dadurch zusammengehalten dass
die Leute wählen können ja oder das ist
eine nicht korrupte Polizei gibt ne das
sind sozusagen Voraussetzungen ja oder
das ist unabhängige Gerichte gibt und so
das sind alles wichtige Voraussetzung
aber das ist ja nur die Hardware ja und
ohne die Software von Menschen die das
auch Leben funktioniert nicht also wir
würden uns wenn diese Entwicklung so
weitergehen würde ja das bin ich halt
jetzt nicht ganz sicher ob das so ist
wir jetzt mal nicht schwarz mal aber
wenn diese Tendenzen sich so in dem
gleichen Tempo weiter verstärken würden
wie sie das zuletzt gemacht haben dann
würden wir uns selbst abschaffen also
der Ersatz von Sarrazin deutschland
schafft sich ab ja der würde sich nicht
auf die erster Linie auf die Frage
beziehen die Sarrazin im Auge hatte über
die Frage aus welchen App nehmen wir
zusammengesetzt sind und wie das
Intelligenzniveau aussieht sondern es
wird den es gibt viele Punkte wo man
sagen kann dass Deutschland sich
abschafft und ich glaube dass die der
größte Anschlag nicht nur auf
Deutschland auch verbraucht auf liberale
Demokratien eben daran besteht dass die
Menschen ihren gemein sind verlieren
dass sie ihren Vertrauen verlieren und
dass sie so narzisstisch werden das
Gemeinschaftsbildungen nicht mehr in dem
Ausmaß funktionieren wie sie das für das
Funktionieren eines guten Staatswesens
notwendig sind also wenn sozusagen das
dass ich ultimativ in den Vordergrund
gestellt wird also nicht
jeder stellt sein ich irgendwo in den
Vordergrund ja
und die anderen weniger offensichtlicher
genau aber es gibt ja auch sowas wie ein
ich im wir oder ein wir im ich das heißt
also die Frage für deinen ich ja wie
viel anderes ist dafür wichtig und
welches andere ist für dich wichtig das
andere dich toll finden ja oder dass du
mit anderen gemeinsam was auf die Beine
gestellt hast oder dich um andere
gekümmert hast das sind ja
unterschiedliche Dinge
und wenn es am Ende nur darum geht die
eigene Eitelkeit zu bestätigen und dann
hat man einen narzissmussproblem dass
ich für therapiebedürftig halte
ich meine die Frage die man sich ja
stellen muss ist wer es eigentlich das
Thema sind es unsere Kinder oder sind
wir es also die die Forschung ist da
relativ eindeutig sie sagt in
Deutschland gab es noch nie so viele
unglückliche Kinder wie im Moment ja die
Kinder sind unglücklich sprachlich
defizitär
sozialauffällig unser das ist das was da
beschrieben wird ich werde ein
einschränkeneinsatz machen ja wenn wir
heute ausrechnen gucken wie unglücklich
unsere Kinder sind dann dürfen wir nie
vergessen dass wir uns heute für die
Frage wie glücklich unsere Kinder sind
wissenschaftlich Aufbereiter Basis
interessiert richtig in meiner
Generation hat niemand untersucht wie
glücklich Kinder sind das muss man mal
dazu sagen ne also die haben keine
echten Vergleichszahlen zu früher ist
richtig ja sie sich genauso das aber die
Frage ob Kinder glücklich sind oder
nicht haben wir alle auch so ein feines
Gespür dafür ich will auch nicht
unbedingt sagen dass die alle sozial
auffällig sind ich erlebe auf der
anderen Seite schon häufig darüber
gesprochen diese junge gener schon als
nicht nur unheimlich informiert da kommt
auch wieder das ganze smartphone-thema
und das Netz entspielt die kennen sich
wirklich aus viele sie sind auch
gleichzeitig unheimlich empathisch die
haben gemein sind ich ich habe keinen
ich habe nicht dieses dieses ganz
pessimistische destruktive Bild dieser
dieser Jugend von heute überhaupt nicht
ja ich mag die das sind das sind
empathische Leute der großteil von denen
aber gleichzeitig merkst du halt auch so
eine
wie soll man sagen sind die Hyper
perfektionistisch zum Teil ist es ist
dieses du kriegst die ganze Zeit
sozusagen im in sozialen Netzwerken
tiktok das sagt sie Herr Müller ist
eigentlich das Thema aber dass man reden
muss vor allen Dingen tiktok du kriegst
die ganze Zeit Instagram natürlich auch
gezeigt wie perfekt
die die Kinder nebenan sind ja und dann
entsteht daraus dann ungeheuriger Druck
da irgendwie mitzuhalten und
das zweite ist diese diese diese
das ganze Thema mit mit Filtern und so
weiter da entsteht ein neues
Schönheitsideal den du niemals gerecht
werden kannst
Operationen genau es gibt es gibt
Berichte von Schönheitschirurgen die
sagen zu mir kommen Kinder und
Jugendliche die sagen ich möchte so
aussehen wie mein tiktok oder Instagram
Ebenbild oder oder früher Frauen sagen
operiere mich bitte möchte gerne einmal
so aussehen wie ich auf meinem Account
aussehen also das dein steht etwas eine
Anspruchshaltung und dann
Perfektionismus den du niemals gerecht
werden kannst das funktioniert nicht ja
also das erste was ich sagen würde ist
ein großer Unterschied der jungen
Generation heute zu früher ist in
unserer Generation das wird dir nicht so
ganz anders ergehen Gang sein in deinen
ja nicht nur schön dolomitischen Bergen
Eltern waren unter anderem damit
beschäftigt ihren Kindern zu große
Sensibilität auszutreiben
also wenn man Junge war dann sollte man
auch irgendwann ab einem bestimmten
Alter WLAN ein Mann zu werden vielleicht
sind wir die letzte Generation in der
das eine Rolle gespielt hat in
Deutschland oder in
Norditalien es gibt ja noch Kulturkreise
in meiner Generation also bei mir nicht
nicht in meiner in meiner Kindheit
irgendwie ich so dieses Gefühl ich muss
irgendeine Männlichkeitsbild
entsprechend gar nicht ja in meiner
Kindheit durch meinen Vater auch nicht
aber so diese Sprüche Indianer kennt
keinen Schmerz und so die die
gehört jungen Weinen nicht das habe ich
nicht von meinen Eltern gehört aber
natürlich von vielen anderen gehört also
es ging darum also den Kindern zu
sensibel waren haben die Eltern sich
eher Sorgen gemacht und das ist heute
anders also Kinder können ihre
Sensibilität ausleben und wenn man seine
Sensibilität weiter auslebt dann kann
man auf der einen Seite eben du gerade
gesagt hast in einem viel größeren Maße
empathisch sein als früher aber auf der
anderen Seite sind eben sehr sensible
Menschen auch sehr viel verführbare ne
und vielleicht dazu Cachen und von
Aufmerksamkeit Räubern einzufangen und
auf falsche Gleise gesessen
und das ist glaube ich das was ich
verändert hat also früher waren die
Kinder nicht von sich aus sondern durch
ihre erziehungsumstellung ein bisschen
abgehärtet da ich meine auch in meiner
Generation war das eine normale völlig
legitimierte und auch nicht bestraft
Erziehungsmethode seine Kinder zu
schlagen
und das ist etwas was Gott sei Dank
heute deutlich anders gesehen wird das
heißt also wir haben es jetzt sehr viele
Dinge machen wir richtiger als früher
gemacht worden sind aber wir kriegen
eine andere Art von Problemen das ist
das eine das heißt auf der einen Seite
hast du da diese Eltern Generation der
Generation alphaiers hinter die die
gerade da so heranwachsen die sind
leistungsorientiert die sind so Hyper
perfektionistisch und auf der anderen
Seite also die berühmten Helikopter
Eltern und auf der anderen Seite aber
lassen wir offensichtlich zu äh und das
machen wir gar nicht glaube ich
großartig bewusst aber wir nehmen in
Kauf dass unsere Kinder sozusagen auf
der anderen Seite wir über behüten sie
und auf der anderen Seite lassen wir sie
digital verwahrlosen das das
funktioniert doch nicht dass das diesen
Konflikt muss man doch irgendwie
auflösen also was täglich erlebe ich
weil ich ja mein Leben in vollen Zügen
genieße und ständig mit der Mann
unterwegs bin
wie Eltern ihren zum Teil sehr sehr
kleinen Kindern im Moment gebraucht ja
sehr gut ja sehr sehr kleinen Kindern
ihre tabletsvorsitzen und das
Erstaunliche ist es funktioniert irre
gut naja klar die Kinder nörgeln und
wissen sich nicht zu beschäftigen und
dann wird das Tablet dann wollen sie das
haben und dann können kaum reden können
da kaum sagen wie es heißt und dann wird
Ihnen das vorgesetzt und dann Flimmern
da Bilder hin und her und dann sind
Kinder drei vier Stunden lang an diesen
Welten gefangen
das heißt das Kind lernt nicht mit dem
Zustand ich weiß nicht was ich tun soll
umzugehen mit dem Zustand Langeweile ne
Langeweile
wird ausnahmslos als negativ empfunden
na und deswegen steht nichts aus dieser
Langeweile heraus und das ist wird
sofort abgetötet es gibt so viele Droge
und für die Eltern ist das natürlich
wunderbar weil die können sich damit
ihren Welten beschäftigen egal was sie
dann in dem Moment machen und die
Verführungskraft dafür ist riesig und
ich kann aus meiner Erfahrung sagen das
sind ja nicht alles debradierte Familien
in denen das stattfindet und das ist
normale Mittelstandsfamilien auch
kulturspezifisches ist interessant es
gibt offensichtlich andere Kulturen die
sich diese Gedanken und Sorgen darum
überhaupt gar nicht machen das fällt mir
also jedes Mal auch wieder auf und dann
ist das so dass die die Kinder sind
glücklich die Erwachsenen sind glücklich
und was das mit den Gehirnen der Kinder
macht ist dann die ganz ganz andere
Frage aber eigentlich du sagst die sind
glücklich sie sind also im Moment sind
die Kinder Glück das Thema ist erledigt
genau
der Mensch hat ja zwei verschiedene
Glückszustände ne also eine ist
sozusagen das Glück im Augenblick und
das andere ist das Bilanz Glück ne und
das ist das was ich meine wenn er den
ganzen Tag verdaddelt hast oder
rumgegamed hast oder sowas dann war sie
die ganze Zeit hoch erregt viel Dopamin
und so weiter und haben bisschen leer
und erschöpft ja als findest sondern
Kater hast
und das bilanzglück ist du hast den
ganzen Tag irgendwas gemacht wo du
selbst drin vorgekommen bist und gehst
du am Abend zufrieden ins Bett da ist
der Erregungsgrad im Augenblick kleiner
gewesen Dopamin Ausschüttung kleiner
gewesen ja aber es waren auch viele
andere Stoffe daran beteiligt die dann
diesen Glückszustand am Ende ermöglichen
und so ist das ja auch im Leben wenn du
ein Leben hast das nur aus kickst
besteht wirst du nicht unbedingt auf dem
Sterbebett sagen du hast das optimalst
mögliche Leben gehabt das heißt also die
Summe der Lebenszufriedenheit ist mehr
als die Addition von Glücksmomenten
und das ist aber so dass der Mensch
darauf aus ist wenn er in der Situation
die Wahl hat ja Krieg nämlich den Kick
ja oder gehe ich an den Kick vorbei dass
er dann gerne den Kick nimmt und
deswegen mein Vorschlag seit ewig lange
Zeit schon als ich mein bildungsbuch
geschrieben habe wenn wir viele Eltern
gar nicht erreichen und ich wüsste auch
gar nicht wie wir die erreichen soll ja
dann müssten die Schulen diese Situation
komplettieren
so und die beste Form wäre dass man in
der Schule etwas einrichtet wie
Meditation ja ich gebe ja den Begriff
Fach nicht so ich will jetzt nicht sagen
in fachmeditation sondern das Meditation
ein integraler Bestandteil der Schule
ist das heißt dass man über einen nicht
geringen Zeitraum meine nicht 5 Minuten
ja sondern durchaus eine Stunde oder
zwei Stunden mitunter nicht jeden Tag in
der Woche dass man dann
Aufmerksamkeitstraining macht also die
fähigkeitsversammlung die Fähigkeit sich
zu bewahren sich nicht zu verlieren sich
nicht an Reize hinzugeben dass man die
trainiert also das kann der
Religionslehrer gerne zusammen mit dem
Sportlehrer machen das kann man
praktisch machen würde man legt sich auf
eine matte ja und soll sich auf einen
bestimmten Punkt an der Decke
konzentrieren und dann werden
irgendwelche flackern den Lichter und so
gezeigt ja und man guckt euch die
Aufmerksamkeit da nicht weggeht und man
übt das und so
Versenkungen Konzentration das ist eine
der elementaren Schlüsselfähigkeiten die
wir in diesem Leben brauchen und wenn
die Schulen das nicht sondern sich
stattdessen was ich nachvollziehen kann
ständig darüber beschweren ja dass die
Kinder sich nicht auf eins konzentrieren
können aufmerksamkeitsspannen singen wir
das hier sinken dass sie ständig Kicks
brauchen sie müssen aktiv was dagegen
tun das muss ein in jeder Schule
angefangen im Kindergarten integraler
Bestandteil des Bildungssystems werden
du hast erinnerst du dich hier im
Podcast hast du mal so so was gesagt wie
der der Reichtum an innerer Welt ja mit
umso größer je weniger Einflüsse von
äußerer Welt da ist ja also wenn gar
keine Einflüsse von äußerer Welt da sind
das ist auch schrecklich ne dann
entwickelt sich nichts das muss ein
gesundes Mischungsverhältnis da sein
aber kreativität entsteht aus Langeweile
ich habe glaube ich im Podcast auch
schon erzählt dass mein Sohn diesen Satz
von mir gehasst hat er immer gesagt ein
paar mir ist langweilig ja super ja das
ist der zuständig versuchen so lange wie
möglich anzuhalten und so na das ist
natürlich schon sehr früh ironisiert und
seine Witze darüber gemacht und so aber
es hat häufig auch funktioniert
dann habe ich gesagt ich muss das ja
noch zu Ende arbeiten dann bist du da
mit deinen quartettkarten oder womit der
beschäftigt war und siehe da wie von
Zauberhand ja irgendwann fängt man an
diese Karten in irgendeine Form zu
sortieren oder sie zu beleben ja und
wenn ich dann eine halbe Stunde später
dazu kam war er im Spiel versenkt genau
und dann fangen Kinder an
Selbstgespräche rausspiele und plötzlich
merkst du wie die stundenlang einfach so
darin verschwinden ich es gibt gibt
diesen diesen es ich glaube irgendwann
auf auf Twitter Magnum amerikanischer
Comedian der hat ein schönes Bild
benutzt er sagte Social Media das ist so
wie die ganze Zeit immer wieder in den
Kühlschrank zu gucken ja und wenn da
nichts gescheites drin ist dann guckst
du so lange da rein bist du irgendwann
etwas findest was möglicherweise für
deine Gesundheit gar nicht gut ist er
fängt an plötzlich Dinge zu essen die du
eigentlich gar nicht essen solltest das
ist glaube ich gut beschrieben schönes
Bild ja
Silke Müller sagt wir haben das Herz der
Kinder vergessen ja also die Idee das
sozusagen Erziehung im Grunde nichts
weiter ist als vorleben und Liebe und
sonst nichts aber wenn du das beides
ernst nimmst also einerseits diese Liebe
ja von der wir sagen ja die ist
natürlich da oder dingbar ist da gar
keine Frage natürlich lieben wir alle
unsere Kinder heißen und ihn nicht und
sagen denen das auch tausendmal am Tag
aber der andere Teil das Beispiel das
Vorleben ja
das ist der entscheidende Punkt und da
habe ich das Gefühl dass wir als Eltern
Generation da teilweise katastrophal
Versagen katastrophal Versagen dieses
dieses immer nur so für für Bruchteile
von Sekunden da sein wirklich da sein
also schaust dann kurz vom iPhone hoch
oder vom Smartphone hoch wenn wenn dein
Kind dich irgendwie anspricht aber
eigentlich bist du in einer völlig
anderen Welt unterwegs und eigentlich
nervt das nur dieses Geräusch dass da
jetzt von außen kommt deswegen ist und
Beziehung auf diese Art und Weise nicht
entstehen deswegen die Frage Richard ich
meine was tun wir ich meine wir haben
wir haben irgendwann gefangen angefangen
Drogen zu echten wir haben angefangen
sehr kritisch über Nikotin nachzudenken
wir haben angefangen sehr kritisch über
Alkohol nachzudenken das jetzt gerade
wieder ein sehr interessant den
Moldawien gesehen da sehen einfach
Männer meines Alters den völlig anders
aus weil sie alle rauchen weil sie alle
offensichtlich auch viel zu viel trinken
das heißt so aus wie die Deutschen 50er
Jahren genau gesellschaftlich sozusagen
völlig akzeptiert dass man viel zu viel
trinkt und auch viel zu viel
trinken genau und das meine ich jetzt
auch gar nicht respektieren einfach nur
an der andere
die Debatte hat da so noch nicht
stattgefunden
und die Frage ist müssen wir irgendwann
dazu kommen dass wir uns Regeln geben
also brauchen wir so einen weil sie
nicht an den Smartphone Knicke müssen
wir Wege finde ich gut ne wie setzt man
so ein Knie um
also wie kommt man dazu bestimmt das
Mega auffälliges Smartphone nutzen zu
echten sollte man es in der Bahn so
machen
ist in dem Ort des unangenehmen
Telefonierens ne es ist immer auffällig
wie laut Leute die in der Bahn
Telefonieren in ihre Handys schreien ne
dass das ganze Abteil das mitkriegt und
für mich immer interessant zu sehen was
für Belanglosigkeiten Menschen sich
dabei alle erzählen vorstelle da kann
man eine halbe Stunde nur darüber
telefonieren das werde ich in meinem
Leben nicht mehr lernen jetzt könnte man
ja sagen wir machen das bei der Bahn
umgedreht wir machen ein einziges Abteil
wo man empfangen hat ja und alle andere
machen wir Ruhe abteilt das wäre jetzt
sozusagen sanfter Druck und wäre
juristisch völlig in Ordnung aber das
wäre ja schon mehr als man jetzt hat
Abteil wo man am Anfang hat in der was
stimmt natürlich das ist wichtig
kontinuierlichen Empfang das wäre ja
kein keine Einschränkungen
also wahrscheinlich gab es früher ich
weiß es nicht ne habe ich vermute mal
früher durfte man überall in der Bahn
Rauchen vermutlich mal und dann kamen
Nichtraucher und geraucht ja und dann
kam Nichtraucher Abteile auf so die gab
es schon als ich Kind war aber
wahrscheinlich gab sie gar nicht
Anfängen da waren gab sie mit Sicherheit
nicht dass man sich darüber gar keinen
Kopf gemacht
wahrscheinlich in 60er Jahren und
irgendwann bestand ein dann die Bahn nur
noch aus Nichtraucher Abteilung an einem
total stinkenden Raucher waren
und irgendwann war auch der Weg richtig
und könnte man das jetzt hier nicht so
beim Smartphone ähnlich machen man sagt
also hier wo die ganzen Geschäftsleute
die da immer zwischen Rheinland und
Frankfurt unterwegs sind nicht die
müssen auf ihre Handys gucken weil die
Arbeiten im Zug so und ich hatte schon
mal in einem Gespräch mit Sigmar Gabriel
ausgerechnet mit Sigmar Gabriel ich war
mein Sigmar Gabriel Essen und wir haben
über viele wichtig ist schon lange lange
her wie viel was hast du zu deiner
Verteidigung vorzubringen
Alter Kanzlerkandidaten okay oder werden
wollte wir werden wollte und damals
lange unterhalten und es gab nur eine
einzige Idee von dem was ich ihm alles
so erzählt habe dir gut fand alle
anderen Vater total doof und die einzige
Idee war dass ich dachte wir schaffen
die erste Klasse ab und ersetzen die
durch arbeitsabteile weil es nämlich ein
Witz ist das selbst schon mal viel Geld
bezahlt und erste Klasse fährt man das
Pech haben kann dass man nicht mal einen
kleinen Tisch vor sich hat wo man seinen
Laptop draufsetzen kann
warum machen wir nicht statt erster und
zweiter Klasse arbeitsabteilung nicht
arbeitsabteile damit die arbeiten denn
damit ihren Ellbogen und ihren
ausgebreiteten Sachen nicht die den
anderen den Platz wegnehmen ja und
umgekehrt die anderen Nerven weil jemand
arbeiten will das könnte man ja trennen
und dann würde man das machen und dann
würde man diese arbeitsabteile da würde
man den ultimativen Empfang herstellen
den man bis heute nicht hinkriegt und in
den anderen gibt es keinen empfang zum
Beispiel im Speisewagen dürfte es keinen
Empfang geben wird sich nicht
durchsichtig schwierig ja würde ich mir
auch nicht gefallen lassen ja deswegen
meine ich ja doch das hört man sich
gefallen lassen sich das auch gefallen
lassen dass sie alle zusammen gequetscht
nachher in einem einziger rauchen ist
ein anderes Thema ja ich weiß aber
gefährlich andere genau und beim
Smartphone gefährdet man andere nicht
man Nerven also genau genau und wenn
nicht da drin vor mich hinlese und so
weiter den gefährlich gar niemanden und
nerve so Markus ich habe ein hilflosen
Versuch gemacht jetzt bist du dran weil
ich meine wenn wir schon über ein
Smartphone Knie reden dann müssen wir
uns auch Ideen anderes denken wie man
den umsetzen also ich ich glaube es
individuell jeder auf seiner ganz
persönlichen Ebene wäre es natürlich
interessant wenn du sagst was auch für
wir treffen uns heute wir gehen essen
wir geben unsere Smartphones ab wir wir
oder auch zu Hause grundsätzlich am
Tisch die Dinger sind irgendwo weit weg
dass man es gar nicht in Versuchung
kommt ich glaube dann wird dann erster
Moment von Langeweile entstehen weil
Menschen wirklich wenn du 88 mal am Tag
dahin greifst das machst du auch beim
Essen mal kurz drauf gucken ist doch
nicht schlimm doch ist es bist du jedes
Mal sozusagen wieder raus und immer ist
diese Aufmerksamkeit woanders ich glaube
das könnte man einfach individuell
verabreden aber mein Thema das ist soll
jeder machen wer will deswegen sagte ich
tolerant bis zum geht nicht mehr mein
Thema ist das was wir mit Kindern und
Jugendlichen da machen und ich ich kenne
nicht die Lösung aber seit diesem
Gespräch mit mit Silke Müller und wenn
man dann anfängt mal wirklich in die
Tiefe zu gehen und ist das Ganze
Potenzial und die die diese Verheerungen
dieser mobilen Endgeräte an dem Punkt
sieht kann man nur zum Ergebnis kommen
dass man das so nicht weiter laufen
lassen kann wie versündigen uns an
unseren Kindern wir verlieren Sie nicht
nur wir versöhnen uns auch an ihn ich
bin ja in der Diagnose ganz ganz deiner
Meinung aber die spannende Frage ist
eben wenn wir mit Hilfe von staatlichen
verboten nicht allzu weit kommen jetzt
könnte man auch sagen ja Moment
juristisch könnte man doch eine Menge
machen also wenn wie kann das denn
überhaupt sein das hinrichtungs- oder
kastrationsvideos auf oft auf Handys von
zwölfjährigen laufen ähm kann man nicht
irgendwie anmelden dass dieses Handy das
Handy eines Kindes ist und dass das dann
grundsätzlich solche brutalen Filter hat
das sowas da nicht durchkommt ist das
technisch völlig ausgeschlossen müsste
man nicht sehen Hersteller des Handys in
die Pflicht nehmen dass da so eine
Schranke drin ist die sowas
grundsätzlich nicht zulässig ich kaufe
dann bewusst ein Kinderhandy und dann
ist von Anfang an sichergestellt dass
sowas nicht durchgeht also
das wird jetzt jeder der was von Technik
versteht wird das wahnsinnig naiv finden
was ich da erzähle entweder kann man das
schon und tut es nicht oder man kann es
nicht ja vielleicht ist auch völlig
ausgeschlossen
irgendwann ganz ganz zuverlässig und
super könnte ich frage mich nur gerade
hier das ist doch nicht die Lösung des
Problems dann hast du halt die Gewalt
Videos die die die Videos mit die die
auch sexuelle Gewalt zeigen und so
weiter dann hast du das Weg okay dann
hast du meinetwegen die Pornografie Weg
okay
genau das ist der Punkt und Du und Du
hast du hast nicht weg sozusagen das das
Bild auch von gerade Mädchen ja dieser
Tage eine Studie gelesen das Mädchen war
nie die
Problembären in der Schule muss man
sozusagen
gemacht in den vergangenen Jahren weil
die unkonzentriert abgelenkt sind
Problem und Mädchen sind die Lösung so
richtig das ganze Schulsystem ist sehr
stark auf Frauen ausgerichtet weil es
auch diese enorm körperliche Motorik die
bei Jungens im Durchschnitt nicht bei
jedem einzelnen aber ausgeprägter ist ja
also Jungs müssen sich müde toben um
sich konzentrieren zu können um die
Schule nie adäquat irgendwo Rechnung
tragen können weil du sozusagen da das
biologische Programm also abgesehen von
Mädchen im Prinzip auch aber bei Jungen
noch stärker auf diese dieses
körperliche toben und ausleben ein
bisschen zu raufen und sowas
ausgerichtet ist und wenn es dafür keine
Lösung gibt ja dann ist das sozusagen
das gerät man in diese innere Spannung
und was passiert jedem wird ADHS
diagnostiziert und so weiter also da
hatten
nie Verdacht und das ist
die versteckte die sehr versteckte
Hochbegabung
verbinde nein aber jetzt Mädchen die
plötzlich signifikant offensichtlich
zurückfallen in Fächern wie Matte und so
weiter ja und ganz grundsätzlich
schulische Leistungen die runtergehen
hat was zu tun offensichtlich mit mit
verloren gehen da Konzen
infektionsfähigkeit und so weiter so und
also ich bitte Hobby Psychologe aber ich
habe eine Idee davon warum das so sein
könnte wenn du dir das anschaust der der
Grad an Ablenkung wo der mittlerweile
ist das ist atemberaubend es gibt den
ganzen Tag Bespaßung Entertainment von
morgens bis abends das ist das Gegenteil
sozusagen von konzentriertem lernen und
auch die Frage was was bringen wir den
bei also was Leben mit den Kindern vor
Anstrengung echte Anstrengungen sich auf
irgendetwas wirklich fokussieren das ist
doch alles das genaue Gegenteil davon
das ist Zerstreuung das ist alles ist
leicht alles alles
vermeintlichen Leistungsgesellschaft ja
weil Leistung gewundert kaum noch einer
ja man bewundert Erfolg
und das richtig bekanntermaßen zwei sehr
verschiedene Dinge ja also Prinz Harry
hat einen enormen Erfolg und eine enorme
Reichweite ohne dass deswegen dahinter
eine große Leistung stehen muss
das gleiche gilt auch für den ein oder
anderen der der öffentlichen Fame
bekommen hat ohne dafür groß etwas
geleistet zu haben und das wird in
absolut
wundert weil dieser Zustand des berühmt
Seins das tolle ist ja und nicht die
Leistung die man erbracht hat auf dem
Weg dorthin zu kommen
und das verändert natürlich die
Wahrnehmung weil früher konnte man immer
sagen wenn ihr die richtig anstrengt so
was leistet dann wird was aus dir ja und
wenn einem aber vorgelebt wird dass
unglaublich viele Leute irgendwie ganz
ganz bedeutendes da sind und einer Szene
sind die relativ wenig geleistet haben
dann gilt das einfach nicht mehr damit
ist sozusagen der Leistung als das
Benzin was ich tanken muss wenn ich
irgendwas schaffen und erreichen will
das gilt halt oft sehr weitgehend für
unsere Gesellschaft nicht mehr
ich als abschließend Lösungen
sieke Müller sagt wir brauchen Social
Media Sprechstunden
gehst du mit
ja kann man machen also ich bin ich bin
nicht dagegen die überforderten Eltern
dürfen nicht allein gelassen werden
deswegen finde ich das gut die Kinder
können auch dabei sein
ich meine das weiß Silke Müller auch das
sind keine Allheilmittel das weiße
genauso
irgendwas muss man ja machen dass man
nicht so dann kann man sagen dass ja
warum soll man das nicht machen ja
digitale Bildung digitale Ethik ja
digitale also Ethik ne Moral müssen
Vogel können
speech Fake News deep Fakes das ganze
Thema ja aber der nutzt die Theorie so
wenig also wenn ich jetzt ein Fach habe
indem ich im Zweifelsfall noch Klausuren
schreiben soll zu dem Thema digitale
Ethik dann werde ich mein Verhalten
nicht ändern ich ändere mein Verhalten
dadurch ich gucke ja mein Verhalten
schon meinen Eltern ab ich gucke mein
Verhalten wegen bestimmten Alter in der
Pubert vor allen Dingen gegen den
gleichaltrigen ab und die Ethik die ich
entwickle ist meistens die Gruppen Ethik
der Menschen mit denen ich umgeben bin
so theoretisches Nachdenken über Ethiker
die wenigsten Menschen zu moralischen
Menschen gemacht
auch hier gilt genau das gleiche das
sollen wir machen da müssen wir darüber
reden das muss Unterrichtsstoff werden
ist es auch manchmal schon ja aber auch
das ist natürlich ein leider relativ
kleines zahnloses Mittel was ich gut
finde sie sagt online spielen nur die
Eltern auch selber ausprobiert haben
leuchtet mir ein wie überprüft man das
das ist die Frage aber das das wird
technisch wahrscheinlich gehen mein
Amazon nie ein Online-Spiel machen
können weil ich mich dafür nicht
interessiere
ich habe noch nie ein Online-Spiel
gemacht in meinem reichen
doch Pac-Man aber das war glaube ich
kein klassisches Online-Spiel aber dann
zum Beispiel diese Regeln haben wir
gerade schon übersprochen gemeinsames
Familienessen ohne Fernsehen ohne Handy
also Dinge die eigentlich klar sein
sollten und ganz wichtig nachts
Smartphone nicht ins Kinderzimmer weil
das was dann kann man relativ einfach
beherzigen das kann man der Gesetzgeber
nicht durchsetzen ne aber das könnte man
doch sagen also im Freundeskreis wie ja
du lässt deinen Kindern das Smartphone
offen auf dem Nachttisch liegen oder im
Bett oder so ist natürlich ein Kampf und
Krieg nee das große Problem sind ja
heute nicht mehr so durchsetzungsfähig
ihren Kindern gegenüber wie früher waren
sie zum Teil mit brachialen Mitteln die
wir heute nicht mehr haben wollen also
früher war die durchschnittliche
Erziehung völlig mit heute sehr
autoritär möchte so und dann ist sie was
sehr viel Gutes für sich hat deutlich
weniger autoritär geworden aber viele
Eltern haben eben auch ihre Autorität ja
mit
herkömmliche Art und Weise Strafen
können ja und sie wollen die besten
Freunde ihrer Kinder sein die halten
Eltern nicht aus genau wir halten es
nicht mehr aus von unseren Kindern nicht
gemocht zu werden meine Eltern total gut
dann bin ich ja
keine schlaflose Nacht deswegen also
genau aber wenn deine Kinder dich mit
Liebesentzug bestrafen also nicht du die
sondern die dich ja das das ist keine
schöne Sache
machen ja ich bin total
ich bin überhaupt als autoritäter
Totalausfall ja aber wenn du diese
Automatisierung so wichtig ja dieser
schöne Verbote und Regeln und wir machen
mal folgendes unter 12 Jahren gibt es
kein Handy das hat bei meiner Erziehung
funktioniert also mein Sohn hat vor 12
kein Handy gehabt
allerdings inzwischen ist auch 20 ne das
wird auch immer schwieriger ne die
Grenze sind ja auch immer weiter nach
unten außerdem war kein Mädchen ne wo
also der Handy gebraucht ja noch
massiver ist dadurch dass man sich
wahnsinnig viel zu erzählen hatte und
bin dann an der übersprudelt und seine
Teams Konferenzen und was weiß ich was
alles so zwischen der amberaumt aber das
wäre und da ist einfacher durchsetzbar
wenn man ihn natürliche Autorität
gegenüber seinen Kindern hat und sich
vor Liebesentzug der Kinder nicht
fürchtet sie hat in der Sendung etwas
gesagt was ich sehr interessant fand
meinte du musst Zugang zum Handy deiner
Kinder haben gesagt wie soll ich das
durchsetzen dass das geht doch nicht und
sie sagt es sehr interessant pädagogisch
schlau eingefädelt sagte machst direkt
ganz am Anfang du gibst du gibst ihm das
Handy mit genau der Auflage du sagst
pass auf du kriegst ein Handy aber nur
unter der Auflage unter der Prämisse ich
habe jederzeit Zugang dazu dann ist das
was anderes als wenn du dir sozusagen
und mit Mädchen noch einmal Richard
letzten Satz also dieses
dieses weil Mädchen scheint du sagst
gerade die benutzen das sehr viel mehr
kommunikativ Jungs zocken ja aber die
Mädchen soziale Netzwerke das ist das
Thema überhaupt genau kommunikativer
sind und so weiter
die die Frage auch welches Frauenbild da
so transportiert wird also nicht nur
dieser dieser dieser dieser Narzissmus
der da offensichtlich getriggert wird
sondern auch die Frage des Frauenbilds
ich ich schaue da manchmal mit den
Sätzen drauf und und denke es ist
Wahnsinn wie sich Mädchen oder Frauen
wieder zu Weibchen machen das heißt du
du lässt dich reduzieren einfach nur auf
rein optische Dinge und in dem Fall
meistens sekundär Geschlechtsmerkmale
was passiert da alles hätte es 30 Jahre
Emanzipation nicht gegeben was hätte es
eigentlich schwarzer nie gegeben
ganz oberflächlich allererste Ebene
wirklich nur Aussehen schminken jemand
sein weil man besonders hübsch ist
Einsetzen von Filtern seinen eigenen
Social Media Bild irgendwo auch dann
entsprechend frustriert sein weil das
niemals funktionieren kann weil der
Filter natürlich etwas vorgaukelt was da
im Zweifel auch gar nicht ist das heißt
dann steht ein gigantischer Frust und
eine riesige Diskrepanz sozusagen
zwischen Anspruch und Wirklichkeit wie
löst du das auf also spannend ist ich
weiß nicht wie viel heutige
Feministinnen sich darüber einen Kopf
machen weil ich meinte die Sensibilität
in Umgang mit Frauen ist und das
großartig in dieser Gesellschaft massiv
gestiegen ja wir haben versuchen immer
mehr und mehr in die letzten Reste von
Ungleichbehandlung in der Gesellschaft
auszugleichen und auf Gleichberechtigung
zu gehen und tatsächlich gibt es
parallel dazu diesen gegentrennt das
heißt also da wo es um die Welt des
Kommerzes geht und letztlich ist ja
dieser dieser ganze Narzissmus und
Influenza und Instagram Markt und so
weiter natürlich eine riesige
kommerzwelt man macht sich ja selbst zur
Ware indem man sich ausstellt dass du
möchtest toll und Begehren sein für
einen amerikanischen Mega-Konzern das
kommt noch dazu einerseits sozusagen
Geschäft genau und auf der anderen Seite
möchte man eben auch Verkäufer werden
dadurch dass Firmen kommen die dann mit
dir werben weil du so toll bist und weil
du so viel Follower hast und so weiter
also durch und durch das ganze hat ein
wahnsinnigen wahren Charakter und der
Feminismus hat diese Seite irgendwann
verloren denn als er mal anfing und das
weiß ich ja gut da ich ja das ist einer
feministischen Familie kommen
die Frau als wahre die Frau als Ware war
natürlich ein großes Thema weil der
ursprüngliche Feminismus war ja sehr
links ja das ist ja bei Kapitalismus
kritisch und er hat gesagt wir gehen so
mit Frauen um weil das der
kapitalistische der warenblick auf die
Frau ist ja genau und heute ist
die Männermagazine
Playboy und so weiter die werden Frauen
einfach zur wahre gemacht und zu recht
genau und so weiter genau Misswahlen die
geächtet worden sind
das ist eine einzige Misswahl von
morgens bis abends und zwar häufig auch
noch ohne Gesicht ja aber es ist
sozusagen und das wäre mein Thema näher
zu beleuchten dass der Feminismus heute
nicht mehr links ist
sondern dass er liberal bis neoliberales
also das ist nicht mehr um diese diese
Verdinglichung der Frau in der
commerzgesellschaft geht sondern nur
noch um die nicht Gleichstellung oder
nicht Gleichberechtigung im Zugang zu
gesellschaftlichen Ressourcen und
Gesundheit da etwas von oben oder
verändert hat also ich will das jetzt
nicht behaupten dass das so ist aber ich
finde es spannend meine Perspektive
darauf zu wegen wir können ja auch gerne
meinen Podcast machen mit einer
Feministin um einfach mal zu gucken wie
hat sich der Feminismus auch verändert
ja das wäre spannend auf der einen Seite
große Fortschritte gesehen haben in der
Emanzipationsbewegung auf der anderen
Seite aus der Sicht der früheren
Feministin dramatische Rückschritte
das wird eigentlich viel zu wenig
thematisiert wie Brüche ich das ganze
ist ja das ist der Punkt also jetzt
würden würden die Frauen sagen pass auf
der Unterschied ist wir müssen das nicht
machen wir machen das freiwillig das ist
unser Ding ist mein Körper ich mache
damit exakt das was ich möchte und ist
auch ein gutes Argument kann man ja
alles klar Moment hätte man auch machen
können wenn jemand Porno Darstellerin
geworden ist in den 70er Jahren und
gesagt hat ich habe mir das aber
überlegt ich will das das werde ich
viele gewesen sein aber du sollst
vielleicht auch gegeben haben ja und
seine
trägt dann hätte man das für mindestens
sagen müssen ja gut wenn du willst und
wenn er das ausgesucht ist doch super
das hat man aber nicht so gesehen das
hat man als Verrat am eigenen Geschlecht
empfinde das ist genau der Punkt
deswegen ist das eine interessante These
das Feminismus früher eher links war
wobei ich noch mal also mich irritiert
das ich ich sehe das und vielleicht hat
das auch damit zu tun dass ich ich bin
wahnsinnig geprägt von von Frauen in
meiner Kindheit und Jugend mein Vater
sehr früh verstorben meine Mutter die
glaube ich nie ist etwas über Feminismus
gelesen hat ja und und auch nicht nicht
wirklich im klassischen Sinne sozusagen
der Feministin war im Sinne von ich
trage das vor mir her meine Mutter war
eine ganz einfache bergbauerntochter
aber das war eine die war sowas von
emanzipiert und feministisch also
feministischer kannst du gar nicht sein
und emanzipierter die hat
Eigenverantwortung übernommen der die
ganzes Leben geschaukelt die war
vollkommen unabhängig von irgendwelchen
Männern und das hat mich wahnsinnig
geprägt er die hat eine riesige Rolle in
meinem Leben gespielt spielt sie in
Wahrheit bis heute und deswegen schaue
ich da so drauf und mit tut das in der
Seele weh wenn ich das sehe wie sich
Frauen wieder zu Weibchen machen die
dann irgendeinem Alpha Rüden gefallen
wollen ich verstehe den Frauen die das
tun nicht so empfunden wird mit
Sicherheit nicht sondern dass das als
das eben die Droge der Aufmerksamkeit da
ist dass das ja auch eine Form von
Anerkennung ist wenn man Komplimente für
sein Äußeres kriegt das gibt glaube ich
sehr sehr wenige Menschen die sich
darüber nicht freuen
und die sagen würden ja wieso ich mache
das freiwillig ich mache im Zweifelsfall
auch noch ein tolles Geschäftsmodell
daraus ich bekomme eine warnsiges Maß an
Anerkennung und das was jetzt den
klassischen Feminismus gestört hat dass
Frauenbild was dahinter ist genau da
würde man kein großes Problem damit
haben weil man sagt ja wieso ich bin
zwar auf der einen Seite werde ich jetzt
quasi als Ware oder nur wegen meiner
körperlichen Vorzüge großartig gefunden
aber ich bin ja nicht so ich bin ja
darüber hinaus eine ganz tolle Frau und
eine erfolgreiche Geschäftsfrau und so
weiter also aus der Perspektive
derjenigen die das machen wird es glaube
ich nicht als Problem überhaupt nur
ansatzweise gesehen vielleicht
vielleicht abschließend Richard ein
Gedanke noch wir reden ja gerade so viel
über Narzissmus und Eitelkeit
interessant ist ja im Christentum ist
Eitelkeit ja eine der Toten
das fand ich immer interessant also die
Idee dass sozusagen so ganz
vordergründige Eitelkeit
die man so vor sich herträgt dass das
etwas ist was nicht nur gesellschaftlich
nicht erwünscht sondern auch wirklich
gesellschaftlich geächtet ist und genau
in dem Bewusstsein bin ich auch
aufgewachsen das war uns allen immer
absolut klar also vordergründige
Eitelkeit gehört sich nicht und ich habe
das Gefühl das ist heute fundamental
anders also wir haben das wir haben wenn
ich das jetzt mal aus Alt linker
Perspektive betrachte würde ich sagen
wir haben das Korrektiv zum Kapitalismus
verloren
also der Kapitalismus hat ganz ganz
viele Vorteile sonst hätte er sich nicht
nahezu global so wunderbar durchgesetzt
ja er hat Wohlstand in ganz großen Stil
gemerkt er hat insgesamt auch die
Freiheit in der Welt erhöht wenn auch in
einem gefährlichen Schlingerkurs nicht
immer ja aber in sehr vielen Bereichen
so dass wir also sowas großartiges haben
wie unsere freiheitliche demokratischen
Liberalen Gesellschaften die wir aus
guten Gründen vielen anderen
Gesellschaftsformen für überlegen fühlen
aber je mehr der Kapitalismus
vorangeschritten ist umso mehr ist das
was vorher die Gesellschaften
zusammengehalten hat ins Wanken geraten
also Traditionen Konventionen Normen und
ganz häufig wie du gerade gesagt hast
mit Religion verbunden ne
dem Tugend Katalog der Religion jetzt
finden wir das ja gut dass wir da bis
zum gewissen gerade rausgekommen sind ja
wir wollen also nicht wieder in den
streng katholischen Welten leben die uns
heute zum Teil schrecklich vorkommen
oder man denke auch an die
protestantischen Welten eines immer
Bergmanns ja und sagen mein Gott haben
wir uns da aus etwas fürchterlichem raus
emanzipiert nur das gänzliche schwinden
von korrektiven das am Ende nur noch der
Jahrmarkt der Eitelkeiten und der Markt
übrig bleibt das erscheint auch Menschen
die den Kapitalismus für die mit Abstand
beste Wirtschaftsformen halten und
liberale Demokratien begrüßen zunehmend
macht einem das mulmiges Gefühl wenn man
sagen so richtig am besten funktioniert
hat das ganze als von diesen alten
traditionellen und dem religiösen noch
so ein bisschen Reste da genau die ja so
ein bisschen noch so Korrektiv waren und
so veranstand und Sitte zumindestens
noch ein bisschen nicht nur schlecht ist
sondern vielleicht auch ein bisschen was
gutes getan haben und dass die jetzt so
allmählich gänzlich verschwunden sind
dass das ganz weg ist und dass er nur
noch der Markt übrig bleibt und eine
Wirtschaftsform die bis in die feine
Unterwäsche des Bewusstseins ne darüber
hast ja gerade gesprochen genau und
durch und durch kannibalisiert hat wir
sind also sozusagen dann nur noch ich
AGs und Verkäufer unserer selber und
Steller und machen uns zur Ware und die
Digitaltechnik erforscht unsere Gefühle
und unser Unbewusstes und wir werden
getrackt und so weiter ja und am Ende
gibt es kein jenseits dieses
Kapitalismus mehr so durch und durch
kapitalistische Figuren dort
Kapitalisten unserer selbst und das tun
wir im Dienste von Großkapitalisten das
ist das was mich dabei am meisten stört
wie sind die Sklaven von ein paar
gigantischen digitalkonzernen und das
ist das was mich so so Wahnsinn im
Grunde genommen
und damit und dann auch durchbrechen und
diese Konzerne selber und das ist Puky
dabei da gibt's zwar Gesichter wie Elon
Musk oder Gesichter wie sakabirk ja oder
wieso
aber den gehören diese Firmen ja schon
lange nicht mehr diese Firmen sind ja
einfach auch wiederum nur Ansammlung von
spekulativen Kapital das ist ja nicht
der große Kapitalist wie man sich den
früher vorstellt so der der Feind der
Kommunist ja
der Menschenschinder und Unterdrücker ja
sondern das ist im Grunde genommen sind
das sind ja gar keine Firmen in dem
Sinne wie man sich früher eine Firma
vorgestellt hat ja wie Frau weg oder so
was sondern das sind gigantische
kapitalpools eines Fluiden Kapitals dass
ich von morgen an auf Knopfdruck nach
Saudi Arabien verabschieden kann oder
nach Norwegen oder wo auch immer richtig
also am Ende geht es gar nicht um
Personen wo man sagt er wollte das alles
aus und so weiter sondern es geht darum
dass eigentlich nur noch die Herrschaft
des Geldes und der wahren und so weiter
übrig bleibt und da kriegen auch
Menschen die ihr Leben lang CDU gewählt
haben häufig heute mulmiges Gefühl wohin
läuft das hier alles richtig richtig
genau das
so Richard so viel Apokalypse für heute
ja so viel so viel Apokalypse für heute
und beim nächsten Mal machen wir eine
ganz optimistische Sendung ja ja
optimistisch mögliche Thema was uns
einfällt wo wir nur gute Laune
mitarbeiten können ja ich ich denke mal
so irgendwas wir werden noch darauf
kommen und noch ganz schnell der seine
Hinweis
am Donnerstag 18 mai 22:15 Uhr ähm
Moldawien ungeschminkt würde mich freuen
wenn uns dann möglicherweise sehen ich
glaube lohnt sich Richard danke dir bis
bald ich danke dir tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]